تعرفونه برش الملح بطريقه فريده وباشتذاب
مشاهير العالم لقطع اللحم التي يبيعها
باسعاره الخياليه ولكن هل توقع احد ان
تلاحقه موظفاته بسبب اجبارهن على ارتداء
الملابس القصيره اليكم قصه والتنانير
[موسيقى]
عديده رفعها رجال ونساء من الموظفين
السابقين في مطاعم الشيف التركي الشهير
نصرت في الولايات المتحده بسبب تعرضهم
للتمييز واجباري موظفات بينهم على ارتداء
التنانير القصيره
الموظفات السابقات اكدنا ايضا ان هناك
تمييزا جنسيا في مطاعم نصرت وان الموظفين
عموما يتعرضون للتمييز وفقا لجنسياتهم كما
نجدوا بثقافه عمل يهيمن عليها هرمون
الذكوره في مكان العمل
[موسيقى]
وقال تسعه موظفين صديقين لدى المطعم في
سبع دعاوى قضائيه تم رفعها في نيويورك
وميامي ان الشيف نصرت مهووس بالشهره
والمال كما ضاع بعض الموظفين السابقين ان
غير الاتراك من العاملين تعرضوا لسوء
المعامله والتمييز كما قالت موظفه كانت
تعمل في فرع المطعم في نيويورك طلب مني
المدير العام ان ارتدي تنوره قصيره وكعبا
عاليا وفتحت في الصدر منخفضه في اول يوم
لي في العمل رغم انه كانت هناك موظفه
تركيه تعمل في المطعم في ذلك الوقت ترتدي
زيها المعتاد
وبحسب تقرير نشره موقع انسايدر الامريكي
فان دعا وقضائيه رفعت من قبل موظفه سابقه
بسبب عدم ترقيتها لانها امراه
[موسيقى]
يذكر ان الشيف التركي الشهير كان قد اثار
الجدل اثناء منافسات كاس العالم بظهوره
المفاجئ داخل الملعب والتقاطته صورا حاملا
كاس العالم ما دفع الاتحاد الدولي لكره
القدم الفيفا لاتخاذ اجراءات داخليه
للتصدي لانتهاكات البروتوكول من قبل الشيف
نصرت
[موسيقى]